en direction du coup une salle
d'accouchement on va me faire comme une
péridurale mais c'est pas vraiment ça
pour une anesthésie c'est très dur pour
tous les deux mais heureusement qu'on
est ensemble c'est vraiment pas facile
et ensuite on nous laisse donc le coup
dans une salle même salle pour pouvoir
bien pleurer
vider notre sac pendant à peu près deux
heures alors juste pour indication un
enfant ressemble des choses à partir de
18 semaines puisque c'est à partir de
demain qu'il a des terminaisons
nerveuses je suis enceinte de quinze
semaines du coup le bébé n'a rien senti
cet homme est alors gilles verdez c'est
vous dire non ça ne me dérange pas je
suis de leur côté d'accord qu'il vit ils
vivent un drame à partir du moment où
ils ont exposé la joie d'attendre des
enfants il centre guillemets obligé par
rapport aux gens qui les suivent et je
trouve ça très honnête de leur part même
si c'est douloureux d'exposer la suite
dramatique triste et cette désespérante
parce que sinon on leur reprocherait
d'être là pour les bons moments et pas
pour les mauvais donc si on ne remet pas
en cause tout le business des
influenceurs ce que je ne fais pas je
les soutiens de bout en bout sur cette
décision non mais même au delà en
business des influenceurs c'est pas et
ils ne doivent rien à personne là ils
ont envie ils ont eu besoin de raconter
une histoire intime personnelle
extrêmement douloureuse qui sommes-nous
pour les juger à ce moment là de leur
histoire de couple c'est une histoire
qui est absolument terrible il ils ont
dû prendre une décision qui est
absolument terrible il aurait pu choisir
aussi une autre option ils ont fait 7
septembre ils ont pris cette option là
on a enfin on a pas à dire on peut avoir
nous des ressenti personnel sur sur ça
on peut être pour ou contre peu importe
en revanche on peut pas remettre en
cause le courage qu'ils ont eut pour le
pôle pour le faire et peut-être que ça
peut aussi aider pour une fois aidé
parce que c'est pas simplement un
placement de produit c'est pas quelque
chose là il parle de quelque chose qui
peut toucher au coeur aussi des jeunes
gens qui les regardent qui peuvent
éventuellement surtout dans ces
situations là tu parles moi je la
connais pas du tout mais je sais que
enfin je la suis depuis longtemps ça
fait longtemps qu'elle est dans le
milieu et je pense qu'elle a assez de
follower pour pas se servir de ça pour
en faire du business je pense pas que ce
soit sincèrement ça qui lui rapporte de
l'argent au-delà de ça moi je parle avec
des énormément de personnes qui ont des
problèmes de fertilité
les problèmes pour avoir des enfants des
problèmes des maladies etc et justement
quand je parle avec ces personnes elle
me parle de gens qu'elle suive sur les
réseaux à qui il arrive la même chose et
c'est un appui énorme on se rend pas
compte mais quand il nous arrive quelque
chose à une maladie ou des problèmes je
dois pour avoir des enfants ou à qui il
arrive la même chose c'est vachement
important de pouvoir s'appuyer sur
quelqu'un qui vit la même chose que ce
soit chama avec des millions de
followers que ce soit même des petits
influenceurs avec même 1000 personnes
qui les suivent à partir du moment où
une personne peut se rattacher à
quelqu'un qui vit la même chose comme
les forums qui existe depuis des années
sur internet moi je pense que c'est
important qu'elle le montre et c'est pas
comme ça qu'elle va gagner de l'argent
donc je pense que c'est plus pour aider
les personnes que pour faire du business
qu'elle fait là richard cyril vous
parler du jeu des influenceurs mais je
pense que ce jeu il a des limites moi ce
qui me gêne des as et la mise en scène
c'est pas comme une télé réalité
classique où ils sont suivis par des
caméras qui filment leur quotidien la
cee qui se filment eux-mêmes et qui met
en scène ça en se filmant eux mêmes en
mettant des musiques d'émotion en les
publiant en voulant faire des vues donc
déjà cette envie de faire du buzz entre
guillemets autour de ça elle me gêne
ensuite la décision qu'ils ont prise
elle est extrêmement intime et ça les
regarde mais je trouve que c'est un peu
maladroite de de médiatiser un moment
aussi intimé compliqué parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui ont des enfants qui
sont trisomiques et qui les aime qui
s'en occupe c'est aussi pour ça que
voilà c'est une des financements réagi
parce que voilà alors décision enfin à
poser problème exactement après ça les
regarde sa foi personnelle on a
effectivement personne pour le commenter
mais je trouve que de le médiatiser et
vouloir faire des vues parce que malgré
tout qu'il y ait là peut-être pas besoin
de l'argent mais elle veut le médiatiser
relâché macérer pris ses comptes s'est
repris dans les médias et je trouve ça
un peu maladroit mais vous peut-être pas
voir le mal partout qui te dit qu'elle
n'a pas un coeur et qui veut pas aussi
le faire pour aider les autres personnes
photo grâce à l'aide de l eau si oui si
ce jour voir le mal partout ça se trouve
cette fille elle a un coeur et elle veut
aider les personnes à qui ça arrive mais
je pense que c'est un sujet extrêmement
sensible et un enfant c'est pas un jeu
c'est pas bon
sont extrêmement
le fait de le mettre en scène comme ça à
la manière d'une télé réalité en se
filmant soi même en mettant des petites
musiques émotions qui vont bien je
trouve voici à
bernard bernard c'est qui ces derniers
mois bernard
[Rires]
je ne pense pas que ça ait beaucoup de
monde si elle fait ça quand tu es dans
cette situation là c'est dramatique tous
les gens que j'ai croisés convenues
qu'ont eu ça dans leur vie ils sont
meurtris ils veulent pas en parler et
parfois même ils veulent même pas
refaire d'enfants à cause de ça c'est un
gros traumatisme je pense qu'il doit y
avoir une pudeur guillaume le dis il ya
des faits l'armée veut dire qu'il a fait
quand même des vues la menace que tu
veux pas qu'ils aient les livres sur des
témoignages je suis personne ne t'a dit
le tas leur nom ce que tu as dit à l'ats
valérie moi je suis personne pour juger
ce qui est ce qui est bien ce qui est
pas bien ou ce qui alors vue de faire
c'est afin de faire moi une question m'a
posé une question à laure noualhat on
pose la question on veut juste la vie
d'une personne fortunée non mais non on
me pose la question je trouve ça déplacé
je trouve ça je trouve ça pas bien je
trouve ça pas ben y'a pas de pudeur ya
rien c'est hollande a mis la petite
musique derrière le scénario de
guillaume midi tous les gens qui sont
passés par là je pense moi j'en connais
aucun corps était capable de faire ça
deux films et aucun c'est un moment où
tu pleures c'est un moment où tu restes
avec ton homme vous êtes en train de
vivre un drame d'une vie et elle est en
train d on devient semaine 18 semaines
me demande pas aux gens d'être capable
de le faire on demande où elle a été
capable de le faire donc pourquoi pas si
ça aide les gens mais ça va les ans
antoine avait dans
sa mire sur un sujet qui te peine eu des
malades à paris c gepa les images est
pas une musique derrière g
bd parce qu'elle n'hésite pas à
les dresser peut-être un vieux con peux
t'assurer passage qu'il y pense ça
m'aiderait moi ce que vous lisez pas oui
mais bon c'est pas une raison pour le
dire vous qui l'avez dit merci
j'aimerais bien voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs sur sa merci nordine oui
à 26 un nom à 72% voyez c'est pas du
tout avec un gâteau qui sont contre
vraiment contre vous et ses
téléspectateurs apparemment n'aime pas
vos gueules